we end this difficult week for our
country with a powerful reflection on
loss and how our nation remembers as we
head into memorial day weekend cbs
sunday morning correspondent lee cowan
shares an essay on what he calls our
national
wound when there's a deep wound in this
country
we try to heal it by giving it a day
this weekend is memorial day for example
the day to remember all the service men
and women we've lost on active duty
we celebrate their lives all of those
who aren't with us anymore
to never forget
is woven into our dna
[Music]
we do the same every september when we
pause as a bell tolls for every person
murdered on 9 11.
even those who died of covet have been
remembered on the national mall
and yet
for those we've lost to mass shootings
the ones shot in schools
in workplaces
in churches and in nightclubs
we have no national day of remembrance
there's no monument no grand fountain
no place for us to mourn as a nation
why
well
maybe our gun violence is a scar too
painful to face
it's too random too unthinkable it's
certainly too fresh this is tough
aaron was a good man
a good person
and we all deserve better families
hadn't even buried those lost in the
buffalo shooting before the shooting in
uvalde started
mass shootings have become so common
that
perhaps they're not considered
extraordinary enough to single out
anymore
instead makeshift memorials will have to
do they always spring up in the days
that follow our tragedies
they grow
but then they inevitably dwindle the
candles burn out leaving only a wisp of
smoke
but mass shootings are a national wound
and wounds this deep don't just heal on
their own especially if all we do is
pick at it she dropped her up at school
i didn't know it was gonna be the last
time i would see her we blame
politicians who have adjourned for the
holiday by the way taking with them any
urgency to this matter
we also villainize guns we bemoan the
holes in our mental health system
and around and around it goes
it's a given there will be more gun
violence the only question is where
and how close to home evil will visit
next time
we become a nation constantly looking
over our shoulders when perhaps what we
need to be doing
is looking each other in the eye
finding the courage to bring all of this
to an end
maybe if that day ever comes we can
celebrate that victory
with parades and barbecues too
lee cowan's so well said i look forward
to that i think we should remind people
that all these shootings are preventable
that's why this is so hard as he said
the courage to present this unthinkable
and still so fresh